LET'S HAVE A QUICK LITTLE BREAK
HERE. HAS
SOME LITTLE BACKHANDS AT HIM.
LOOKING TO GEGE
THE PUCK GOES AND I LOOK AT THE
WORK IN FRONT OF THE NET.
FRONT TAKES THE SHOT.  A LITTLE
GOOD HIT BY DAVENPORT.
THAT KEEPS S
DOWN FOR NOW THEY KEEP IT IN AT
THE
!!!.
A RIGHT SAT
THE FIRST ONE OFF THE POST
SINCE IT'S RIGHT THERE.
AND
AY FROM 400 AND HIS CAREER.
COMING OFF A DANGEROUS STICK ,
LIKE TO STRETCH THE ZONE.
THE HAVE TO BE
DOWNLOAD TAKE THE SHOT ON THE K
ME? THEY HAD
PLENTY OF BODIES BACK.
A BEAUTIFUL
THAT BRINGS THE DEVILS WITHIN
ONE.
GLOVE SIDE.
A BEAUTIFUL PASS
>> Play-by-Play: THE PUCK
RICOCHETS OFF.
HERE WE GO.
SEPARATION WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY . THEY COMPLETE THE
BREAKOUT
RAY CARE.